okay [ __ ] it's like a level here with
a main man Kanye and weight are lying
we're playing the greatest mission along
the carrier I gotta rescue this [ __ ]
PDA and tracked on Ulysses into the
temple Oh guys let's do that [ __ ] [ __ ]
ready steady I do I am ready I am steady
his accession of hostilities complete
Ready Steady ID okay how'd he get out of
a you know yes I miss us that all
because like you know like he cared my
[ __ ] firmeza today
hey Dad yeah grateful
okay I thought that Brett cast but fun
like what are my perks anyone [ __ ]
now I'll getting a million here's the
enhanced senses
okay well that's dandy I guess let's
camp [ __ ] I got no ammo in here I got
chat like a dog take that side yeah yeah
okay yeah let's take this out [ __ ] what
am I gonna do bake a cake okay under
stairs now shut ya shut
anyways where's Ulysses
yeah it looks like I know that you can
tell me using
even I single how I
yeah I has a sketch so you came courier
I did not expect what's your number and
one last time kill judging by you either
way you've answered you don't see you
brought the divide to life courier you
and when I saw then you brought the West
in that packet
hmm Anna I honestly I don't know you you
walked after that you taught me that
nothin
yet you
the wat okay sneaking done fighting now
it's a chef pants
hey honey i just hope what account yes
ok amor stimpaks I just get some [ __ ]
gonna hi not let's just go crazy
synthetics
[ __ ] anywhere 8 ok time to [ __ ] them up
that ok sniper rifle no more skin packs
yellow says Alan's like my tie Fanny for
Fido no more compact
[ __ ] ok yeah I let this
I bet if I i can get my speech at i
watch us right just being do and I
speech should be like a hundred
so you came you up you you brought and
you brought the what you just you
destroy
hmm
No
yet
the one the our history there's nothing
my home deal there is blood ma no I oh
that's it ready steady I didn't all
right steady I need some hey all these
drugs yep everyone everyone
come on come on forget Allah that's
[ __ ]
don't I have something to [ __ ] where is
worst impacts come on what is my
strongest weapon
get up yet no more impacts
okay laser detonator
no more stimpaks
no more stimpaks come on come on come on
today
ouch
esic [ __ ] hard a shot is it where the
Ulysses go every shot every shot that's
come in got him I get a stamp pack
anything for that injury hey Chet
and backs better off with an autodoc
suit Jesus no more stimpacks no more
stimpaks your pile
o Allah says she could come now I'll
glory now
should I wear masks
ain't no time to kind of finish all this
[ __ ] I gotta
that's all ready steady I get I think
all the study I had everything like
ninety-five percent how it turns out I
don't know ooh that's nasty Oh
ice will keep you on your feet knocking
hey this is starting to hurt I'm not
gonna lie
the [ __ ]
clean shot or do you think is cute dr.
Klein for dr. Brooks